(audience cheering)
- All right. Let's finish
up with something from
we discovered on social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
So this starts with an
elementary school teacher
in Indiana inviting her boyfriend
to be the mystery reader for her class.
The second graders were
mesmerized by his words,
but the teacher had no idea
the book had a surprise
twist at the ending.
Check it out.
- Now there is something still
missing. Yes. Just one thing.
A beautiful, radiant cut diamond ring.
(kids screaming)
And so, Rachel, here I am
getting down on one knee.
(children screaming)
With all the love in my heart,
will you marry me?
(children screaming)
Yay!
(audience applauding)
- So cool. We have the happy couple
on the line right now watching
on WTHR in Indianapolis.
Let's say hi to Rachel
and Austin everybody.
(audience cheering)
- Kelly, hi!
- Hi, Kelly!
(audience cheering)
- That was such a cool
way to do it, Austin.
Do you think that Rachel,
were you more surprised or the kids?
The kids were squealing.
- Yeah, the kids were squealing.
It's hard to say because I had told Austin
that I wanted a private
proposal, just me and him.
So the entire time I
think they picked up on it
way before me.
Because the whole entire time I'm thinking
there's no way he's gonna do this.
Like he's just being really
sweet in front of my kids.
And it wasn't until he said,
I'm missing just one thing.
I was like, oh, this is really
about to happen right now.
Like he's about to pull out a ring.
- [Kelly] Aw, that is so sweet.
- So I don't dunno. I
think it was a tossup.
- And Austin, did you write
the book that you're reading?
- Yeah. So the Strike Zone
is an Austin Dunwoody original, actually.
I wrote it in my prime in third grade.
The point of the book
as third graders think
I actually turned into a
bowling pin in the book.
- Sure.
- And I had to add one special character,
which was the shiny head pin
at the front of the lane,
which ended up being Rachel
and I brought that out at the poem
right at the end of the video.
- Oh my God. It's so great.
(audience applauding)
It's so awesome too because
kids learning about love,
like my daughter would've been the
loudest Squealer in that room.
- She loves love
- Yeah.
- So much.
But that was so cool that
you shared it with them too.
What a special moment for all of you.
Thank you for sharing it.
I'm liking your posts
right now, all right?
- [Austin] Thanks Kelly!
- [Rachel] Thank you so much.
- Alright, well that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pin, makers of Precise,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate your
engagement with you.
So they're giving you a thousand dollars.
You could put that wherever you want.
(audience cheering)
- Congratulations you two!
You thank you to all our guests this hour,
Edgar Ramirez, Phoebe
Dynevor, Danny Davito,
Victoria Justice, and Toby Gad.
You all have a great
(indistinct) if not, change it.